One of the conversations that we've been having
on the show probably for a year and a half
now, I'd say it
is a conversation about what are the longer
term consequences of this first Donald Trump
term.
The ways in which politics has changed the
ways in which what is acceptable language
and discourse has coarsened.
Uh, we've had a lot of those conversations,
some relate to alliances with foreign countries,
some relate to, well, here's a list of executive
orders that could quickly be undone.
Here's a list of executive orders that would
be more work for the next president to undo.
But one of the most important sort of changes
or effects of the Donald Trump presidency
is on the presidency itself.
And what I mean by that is that the effect
of the effectively told the, uh, the, I don't
want to use that word twice, the effect of
what has been essentially total immunity from
consequences for Donald Trump's actions are
going to be felt not just if Donald Trump
gets a second term, but during the remaining,
uh, of, uh, I guess 11 months of this first
term, Donald Trump believes now that he can
get away with anything and he's right to believe
that because he possibly can.
And this is why I do not believe we will have
a peaceful transition of power in January
of 2021.
If Donald Trump loses in November, look at
all of the things that Donald Trump has gotten
away with, with essentially no consequences.
And I alluded to this earlier in the show
and said, I wanted to talk about it.
You look at the Russia stuff, okay, whatever
your view is on it, his behavior was not perfect
when it comes to Russia, but never where they're
really going to be consequences for Donald
Trump.
From the Mueller investigation, we suspect
that Donald Trump is experiencing some degree
of cognitive decline or confusion.
We don't know exactly what, because we can't
get a, an actual, a workup medically to figure
out what's going on.
But there was no way that the 25th amendment
is going to be used to remove Donald Trump,
the emoluments stuff, the ways in which Donald
Trump has had four foreign diplomats and others
come and stay at his hotel in DC to funnel
money directly into his family business.
And then the bigger ways in which Donald Trump
has funneled money into his own pockets when
he travels to his own clubs and resorts, when
his campaign funnels donor money right back
into his pockets by using donor money to rent
out, um, event spaces and hire catering from
Donald Trump's own restaurants and hotels
and venues.
We've talked about it all before Trump's participation
in Yemen, um, uh, via Saudi Arabia as a proxy
in that completely immoral humanitarian crisis.
There have been no consequences for anything
with impeachment.
Of course.
Now being at the most recent, uh, of being
the most recent example with his acquittal
on both articles this week, getting away with
everything, no witnesses in the impeachment
trial, a prejudged conclusion in coordination
with Senate majority leader, Mitch McConnell,
Trump's personal lawyer, is running all over
the world doing so-called drug deals.
That's what Trump's own.
Former national security advisor, John Bolton,
called them arranging corruption.
He'd now is joking increasingly about being
president longer than the constitution would
allow, and in fact, I know that these are
all, these are like 98% jokes, 2% serious
when he does it.
Post it to Twitter, a video yesterday, which
we're now going to show our video audience
where there are signs flying by saying, Trump
2024 Trump 2028 et cetera.
I get it.
Big joke triggering the libs, all that stuff.
But if Donald Trump loses in November of 2020,
I don't expect a peaceful transition.
I expect claims if it's a close election,
I expect claims that it was rigged or that
the counting was wrong and that he didn't
really lose.
If it's a big margin, if we do the thing I'm
saying we have to do, which is turnout in
such overwhelming numbers that we outdo the
voter suppression and the meddling and the
interference and all of this stuff.
If it's a big margin, Trump will say it's
too big of a margin.
It was obviously rigged, fake, and phony.
It was fraud.
We need a recount or we need an invest in
independent investigation, bring in some kind
of special investigator, prosecutor, whatever.
Now I've said before, Trump won't ultimately
get away with it.
If Donald from blues is in November, I do
believe that it is not going to be the justice
department that saves him.
I believe ultimately Donald Trump is going
to have to leave, but it's not going to be
peaceful.
I still find it odd, by the way, that there
are still so many people that think Trump
will completely peacefully say that.
You know what?
We lost.
We had a good run at it.
Uh, we, I will peacefully transition to the
next president of the United States, particularly
if it's quote crazy Bernie or sleepy Joe or
whoever it is that it will be.
Trump is beyond unhinged.
Trump has already questioned the credibility
of an election he won.
Remember, Trump won in 2016 electorally, he
lost the popular vote.
There is every indication that that is the
reality, that that is not some kind of Farsar
fake phony numbers and Trump questions it.
If Trump spends three years continuing to
question an election, he won.
Imagine what will happen if the guy actually
loses.
So when I say, as I've been telling you guys
for awhile, we need to win so big in November
that they can't cheat or that they can't use
voter suppression to win or whatever.
What I'm essentially saying is that we need
a margin that is big enough that it won't
let Trump deny the democratic process.
And of course, again, if it is a huge win,
he'll still try to deny it by saying it's
too big of a margin.
It's not believable that I would lose by that
much.
Clearly it was rigged.
I'm worried people aren't grasping the magnitude
of this.
We are, you know, uh, as I say before, sometimes
I say it in a positive sense.
A journey of a thousand miles begins with
a single step.
At the same time, the long journey to authoritarianism
also begins with a single step.
And sometimes it moves so slowly that you
can't even notice.
We are well down the authoritarian road at
this point in time when you compare where
we were before Donald Trump was inaugurated,
to where we are today, attacks on media and
suppression of journalists and journalism
that the white house doesn't like.
It's just common.
It barely is a blip on the radar at this point
in time.
Trump regularly gleeful and praising the authoritarian
types that many of us feel are the most anti-American
thing while criticizing our Western historic
Dem democratic allies.
It barely even makes headlines anymore.
And in fact, many Trumpists agree.
They like the Assad Putin, Kim jog, you know,
whoever do territory types and are glad and
agree with Trump when it comes to his criticisms
of Emanuel McCrone or, uh, Angela Merkel or
whoever.
By the way, Angela Merkel, no bleeding heart
liberal to begin with.
So Trump is a symptom of many underlying problems
and not the cause, but he is an exacerbating
symptom.
He is a symptom that is making the problem
significantly worse.
He wants people to believe that voter fraud
is the reason why he didn't win the popular
vote in 2016 even though yes, he won the electoral
college.
Imagine if he loses the election.
Okay?
He will do whatever he can to contest it.
He will try to get it tied up in court if
he will succeed as anyone's guess.
I maintain that.
If he loses, he will ultimately relinquish
power, but I don't believe it's going to be
peaceful.
Let me know what you think about this.